Have you ever felt like you could think more clearly after exercising?
According to Justin Rhodes, an associate professor of psychology at the University of Illinois...
...at Urbana-Champaign, exercising helps blood flow to the brain,...
...and throughout the rest of the body.
When our blood flow and blood pressure increase in a healthy way like from exercising,...
...it gives us more oxygen in our blood and more energy.
Or it could be the hippocampus part of the brain that is used for learning...
...and memory is stimulated during a workout.
Research shows that cognitive function improves when a person exercises,...
...even if it's just for 20 minutes.
Older people who do aerobic exercises can actually counteract memory loss,...
...and students who exercise get better test scores than those who aren't as athletic.
According to research from the University of California Los Angeles,...
...exercise increases the brain's growth of neuronal connections, which make learning possible.
Another study that looked at the effects of exercise on the hippocampus part of the brain...
...showed that running reduces the production of stress hormones.